today we're going to be having our third
conversation with you Ron Brook who is
the chairman of the Aisne Rand Institute
and host of the yeren Brooks show this
is number three in a series of
discussions produced in partnership with
the iron Rand Institute we've talked
about eine Rand and objectivism we've
talked about capitalism and other
economic systems and today we're going
to talk a little bit about welfare
programs we will also talk about
universal basic income so maybe for this
one you're on maybe I'll lay out my view
first and then give you a chance to to
respond to that sure okay so my view on
welfare programs in general and I think
we'll start general and then maybe get
more specific is number one I don't see
any moral case against welfare programs
in principle for me one of the beautiful
things about humans getting beyond a
state of nature into an era of
governments and technology and education
and advancement is that we have the
political and economic resources to set
some floor for the circumstances in
which people will live I don't subscribe
to what George Lakoff calls
strict father morality where I'm
motivated by the idea of teaching people
a lesson by not helping them when we can
in principle I think that there's little
about that that I find convincing that
the people will be better off in some
long-run if no one helps them and they
either die or figure it out or don't or
whatever I don't buy that I do believe
that once you sort of put aside
principles that might be appealing to a
16-year old hearing about libertarian
ideas for the first time and think about
the real world and people and
relationships I think that there are
many positive elements of establishing a
welfare system now any welfare system or
insurance system has some Free Riders
there will be some people who will
overuse the benefits people who will be
motivated not really to use these
benefits as a bridge to better their
circumstances but they want to hang
around and collect 200 bucks and food
stamps or whatever
I don't think policy should be made
around them and I think that in total if
you have a properly run program be it
food stamps or unemployed
or whatever I believe economically it's
a net stimulus and I think that when you
consider the positive externalities
we're doing something good and I'll give
a couple examples and then turn it over
to you you hear stories about people
sitting back and collecting welfare and
being thrilled to live on the government
Dole I don't think anybody's riding high
on food stamps and unemployment if you
want to talk about corporate welfare
then maybe we have something to talk
about but I don't think that's that's
today's subject the small percentage of
people who do find themselves satisfied
by what they can make from welfare
programs I'm just not worried about them
I think most people want to do things
most people want to be productive you
know the non-existent welfare queen with
a Cadillac from the Reagan era never
never existed and we know that if people
can't afford food they'll commit crimes
to get food this taxes our Police
Department's our emotions we feel unsafe
in our neighborhoods we don't go out so
my starting point is everybody it's
society overall benefits in the short
and medium term from properly calibrated
thoughtful welfare programs and in the
long run the Sun expands and engulfs the
earth so I'm not super worried about the
extreme long run that's my framework for
thinking about this sure and it's it's
the framework on which we are gonna
disagree cuz I'm gonna I'm gonna defend
a 16 year old I guess I never go out of
still am that person and I'm I'm gonna
you know I reject on the welfare state
not because of the free white is not
because of the welfare cadillac whatever
i you know i don't really care about
those things i don't think that's the
essential i don't think it's important
whether they exist or not i think the
welfare state is fundamentally and
deeply immoral and it's amal because it
basically negates the rights of
individuals to do as they will with the
wealth that they have that they have
created it is somebody else the
government in this case deciding what is
best use from my resources based on some
standard of social well-being which i
reject which i reject as as being an
even standard the role of government as
we discussed
I mean my view is to protect the rights
of individuals to be free to act freely
to think freely which means they invest
freely to consume freely to give away
their money freely to do whatever they
want with their time their resources and
their mine and the state here comes and
tells me that they have decided that
there is a group over there that needs
my help now maybe it does maybe doesn't
but they have decided that I should help
them and they're not asking me for help
they're not requesting me to help
they are cursing me they're forcing me
they're putting a gun to my head and
forcing me to help that group I reject
violence
I reject coercion I reject force I mean
if you had said I think they're people
who need help and I'd like to see a
society in which there are voluntary
organizations that help people that need
help then you know that's a fruitful
conversation to have but as soon as you
bring in the element of I know what's
good I know it's good for society I know
who needs help and how much up and where
they need help and what programs to help
them and I'm gonna force you to
participate I think now it's an email
system and it's a violation of the very
principle on which government was
established or should have been
established which is the principle of
protecting individual rights not
violating them now I do want to say
something about welfare recipients
because I do think I and I want to say
something about the economics of it too
but I do think that it's also harmful
psychologically in this and in from a
self-esteem perspective or a moral
perspective for people to be on welfare
particularly given that I don't think
the state particularly does charity very
well I think that you know put aside the
borderline cases but I think that a lot
of people who feel like or are
institutionalized into into a welfare
where they expect it and it would
becomes an entitlement and it becomes a
way of life and I think that is horrible
for them I think it's sad for them I
think it's it's it's it's I think the
one thing about charity is it functions
in a way that is usually much more much
more restricted my
more time bound and usually encourages
people to rise up from this state and
take control of their own lives I think
what welfare does to most poor people is
it makes them dependent and that
destroys their self-esteem basically the
state is coming to people and saying
yeah you guys can't take care of
yourself with it because of your culture
with us because of your IQ it's because
of your mentality whatever it is you
can't take care of yourself you need our
help and we're gonna help you and don't
worry we're gonna help you and yes it's
not helped enough to be middle-class but
it's basically institutionalizing people
into poverty and giving them all the
wrong messages and there's no accident
that the warm poverty has done very
little to reduce poverty one last point
cuz you raised a lot of issues it's not
a net stimulus I mean we really didn't
need to get rid of this bogus economic
idea that consumption drives the economy
I mean it drives me nuts because
everybody repeats it as if this is gonna
this is good it's the case what you're
doing is you're basically taking saving
and investment and turning it into
consumption any decent economist half
honest economist will tell you that what
you're doing is yes you're you're
sacrificing long-term economic growth
you're sacrificing long-term economic
prosperity for short-term for short-term
economic growth that's fleeing
consumption by its nature is destruction
when you eat something it's gone it goes
away that's the nature of consumption
investment is what builds things for the
future investment and savings are what
create economic growth for the future
wealthy people who you're taxing or even
middle-class people who you're taxing
but don't consume day money they invest
in and save it and it's that investment
it's saving that you're taking and
you're turning it into so it's net for
the economy negative there's no positive
stimulus I hear Andrew yang talk about
this and I hear lots of economists from
particular persuasions talk about this
this is just not true it's not
economically sound
I don't think Keynes would agree with
this I you know so I think we got need
to get the economics right on top of
everything well I think we do and I I do
think you're you're completely
misstating the economics but let's maybe
come back to that because there were
some things you said earlier that I
want to focus on one thing is you know I
think it's very presumptuous of you to
say that the psychological impact of
receiving a benefit from a welfare
program is that you feel bad about
yourself and unworthy and all these
things but that if you get the same from
charity people feel great I think that
that is a distinction that makes no
sense whatsoever I don't even know that
it really should have much of a part in
our discussion because you can feel okay
or not okay if the money comes from from
government or charity I don't think it
makes a big difference it's a huge
difference the one comes from government
it's a it's it's it's you know you know
that it's B it's money that's mean cause
from other people
you know money's people don't agree with
that framing so I would just most people
donkey taxes hold on but you're on
you're on hold on if most people hold on
a second if most people don't see taxes
as coercion how can you say most people
see the welfare benefits as having been
coerced of course everybody knows taxes
of coercion whether you want to admit it
or not
I mean try not paying your taxes taxes
are not voluntary you can't turn
something that is forced upon you
whether you like it or not into
something that somehow voluntary hold on
seconds but hold let's explore that a
little bit you're on you could you for
the benefit of the audience you're
originally from Israel is that right
that's right okay I'm originally from
Argentina so at a certain point did you
come to the US with your parents or by
yourself I don't know exactly but it's
not hugely relevant but just so I get
the the analogy correct came by myself
okay at a certain point you made the
decision to come to the United States
and when you did that were you ignorant
to the fact that there were taxes here
no but that doesn't change the fact let
me let me make this point if somebody if
somebody emigrates if a Jew emigrates
into Germany when their concentration
camps is it his fault that he gets sent
to them I mean it's a stupid thing to do
but the fact is the evil of killing
people the evil of taxing people of
using coercion against people is not
diminished by the fact that I know it's
gonna happen to me when I come but it's
a little bit different you're a hold on
I don't imagine you're equating
concentration camps to taxes I Mak
waiting coercion coercion is coercion
now true it's a much greater evil much
greater evil to kill people then
is to take their wealth okay fine
oh the evil and they let me just say
this as well look it's not like I have
any options right every states in the
world today causes people well done but
then that's so but I think we allow me
to at least follow it fully through so
you you did you you concede you chose to
come to the u.s. knowing what the system
was but you say that doesn't make the
system any more moral fine I I concede
that it doesn't but then to suggest that
choosing to come to the US knowing the
tax system choosing to stay in the
United States and work and then saying
that you were completely coerced into
paying American taxes that seems like a
bit of a stretch now you're getting to
one of the most important elements here
which is but hold on David other
countries also have taxes that's right
and there's a reason why which is once
you have more than a couple hundred
people who want to live together as
Jared Diamond has written about
brilliantly in his book you need to
delegate some decision-making power and
that's what we call government but
you're sort of getting to making my case
for me no I mean you need to delegate
some decision-making to government but
if government is then and the purpose of
that is to eliminate coercion if
government is then using coercion in
order to so-called eliminate coercion
and it's not it's just the increased
coercion it's it's violating the very
principle and which was put together and
therefore it is it undermines its own
legitimacy but look you know you lots of
situations in life we you can imagine
wit coercion exists and you can't get
out of it you know you you have a little
storefront in the east side of New York
in the early 20th century and the Mafia
comes around and collects protection and
and you know you would you say it's
voluntary that you give them the
protection money well of course it's not
volunteer you because you know the
consequences if you don't pay the
coercion so people say well why don't
you leave the store and go somewhere
else well because it's expensive to
leave the store it's difficult to leave
the store and there might be protection
money you have to pay in the next
neighborhood as well so I'll pay the
protection but you know what I'm still
gonna complain about it I still view it
as a mall that I'm paying the protection
money because it's unjust it's not right
it's not fair and I view what the
government does for takes
for me and give it to somebody else is
the equivalent protection my yes in a
sense they're coming to me and say you
cannot pay and you go to jail you cannot
pay and I'll break your window going
down your store it's exactly the same
thing it's exactly the same form of
force now you you need to just admit
this and say you're okay with some
coercion that is what most people say is
look when we come together in a society
we we accept that there's gonna be some
coercion placed on some people we're
okay with that I'm not and I think it's
wrong and I think it's it's morally
offensive because I think again my view
is the individual coercion against the
individual is always going to be morally
wrong coercion so the initiation of
force against an individual is always
morally wrong and within that framework
government cannot tax the regulate
government cannot tax to redistribute
wealth gum and cannot use cursive
taxation but so the the problem I'm
having is you you've conceded that there
is a voluntary nature to your choice to
come to the United States knowing the
taxation system and to stay here and to
work here and I get it if you do it and
then you don't pay the taxes eventually
someone with a gun will come and bring
you to jail but you still chose to come
to the u.s. knowing there are taxes and
to work now you're saying I still get to
complain about it and you do and I
completely respect and support your your
desire and ability to complain about it
but I don't yet but hold on hold on but
to then take a decision that you concede
was a voluntary one even if you don't
like it and say that the entire system
is coercive versus saying we live in
societies and understand that we are
giving up the ability to decide
everything that happens in the society
because that's how a society works it's
a very it's a game that is partially
linguistic and part ideological that's
being played it's definitely ideological
I'm not against ideology I'm a big
supporter of ideology I have an ideology
sure and and and I think my ideology is
logically consistent but no I I think
what you're saying is completely you
know illegitimate in in in and not
logical the fact that I chose a less of
two evils I could have stayed him in
Israel I considered that a greater evil
tax
Alysha stay
taxes taxes whoa hyah I chose a less of
two evils doesn't make the lesser evil
less evil it's still evil right now it
might be less evil in Israel but it's
still evil and and and I will do
everything I can to reduce that evil
further then you would do the same thing
let's say you believe you came here from
Argentina let's say let's say let's say
you didn't come from Argentina let's say
you came here from Denmark you didn't
come from Denmark but I know people
who've come to the United State from
Denmark okay and and you and you have a
particular point of view a pro welfare
state point of view and you say you know
I don't think the United States is mall
because it doesn't we just you read
enough and people say well why don't you
stay Denmark Denmark they redistribute
more and you would say that's an
illegitimate argument it's okay to come
to the US and argue you're not we just
be enough we should redistribute more
I'm saying it's fine but that's the
difference you're on it's fine to show
up and argue for whatever you think is
best but to claim that you were coerced
into doing it is where I have a problem
with what you're saying sure show up and
say saxs are too high but if course it's
coercion it's it's nothing else but
coercion but hold on you don't have to
come here you didn't have to work this
is the fundamental point I bought this
last time yeah the and by the way I live
in Puerto Rico for this reason because I
chose you know to reduce my taxes even
further and have reduced my taxes
significantly by moving to Puerto Rico
so I am following this and I still can
look at the United States from Puerto
Rico we kind of part of the United
States kind of not and say that's evil
what they're doing that's wrong that's
amore but look I gave this example last
time and I think it holds for welfare
and it holds for the ships of Taxation
my neighbor can come and ask me for help
and I can voluntarily supply him help or
not it's up to me
him getting together with all the
neighbors and voting that I have to help
him that is coercion and that is what
democracy does democracy does not turn
stealing into a virtue it stealing is
stealing is stealing the fact that a
majority voted for it doesn't make it
right now you could say I don't mind I
think that that the fact that you know
we steal is okay because there's some
greater good achieved by it fine but you
have to
not only did stealing because it is the
fact when if something is wrong for an
individual to do it's wrong for group to
do the group doesn't make immorality go
away I don't think that we necessarily
disagree about whether you have 100%
power I guess is the way I would call it
to decide every aspect of what it's like
to live in a country like I just
hesitate to apply the words you're using
because they have significant values a
judgments attached to them that are
divorced from the empirical realities of
being human and living in a group of
more than 150 people I think that's what
maybe becomes frustrating about these
arguments where okay you you weaved you
might be I'm okay with the government
saying if you want to live in this
country and if you want to work which
they're not forcing me to do right I
mean okay I'm choosing if you want to do
those things then here's the way that
it's going to work and I can decide well
on that basis I will it will or won't
work but here's what authority can they
do that so so I I mean the whole the
whole way in which particularly America
is founded is in the principle of
individual not you start with the
government and then the government
decides under what condition it's okay
for you to live under what conditions
it's okay for you to work no the
government the US this comes up often
the US government's the US government's
ability the US government's right to
collect taxes is widely established and
codified if I'd you know I'd have the
citations in front of me had I known
they were going to be necessary I don't
but I've discussed this on my program
the idea that there is no legal basis
for collecting taxes that that has been
wisely debunked oh I'm not gonna argue
that okay now arguing that I'm a
legitimate the fundamental nature and
we're not even argue the history I'm
talking about the fundamental nature of
government okay government is not there
to dictate to me how to live my life
government is there to serve the one
function it's supposed to serve which is
to protect my life and property and that
is it and everything else that it does
in the name of the Social Welfare is
coercive it is by its very nature
forcing me to do things I don't want to
do and that's violating my rights it's
engaged my right to life liberty in the
positive happened okay that that's your
interpretation
many people disagree but I think our
focus has been heavily on your
disagreement with welfare on the basis
of how it's paid for because it's coming
out of your taxes and you don't have a
say let's for a second maybe shift to
the other side of this which is the
issues of the function that welfare
programs can have in a in a society do
you deny the negative externalities of
economic despair that I mentioned during
sort of my opening sure I'm not gonna
come out in favor of economic despair
you know indeed I believe the do that
the correct way to deal with economic
despair is to have you know a government
that does not tax and redistribute
wealth I believe there's a lot more
despair today in America that needs to
be I think people that way too many
people today who are poor in this
country and I think if you unleashed the
economic benefits of capitalism of free
markets of a government that does not
tax away my money that I would invest in
productive activities there would be
many more jobs the jobs would be much an
end by the way if we eliminated the
regulations that we discussed last time
there would be many more jobs much more
economic activity there's zero reason
why the United States economy should be
growing and what is at 1.9% right now it
should be growing at four to five
percent at least at four past five
percent growth
poor people in this country this stand
of living would grow dramatically but to
achieve that you would have to
completely restructure the way we do
things we would actually have to
establish a capitalist economy in this
country which we don't have we yeah but
hold on a couple things on four to five
so number one four to five percent
growth in any sustained way is extremely
rare in countries that are as developed
as is the United States usually only
countries that are not yet as developed
can experience that but and I and you'll
be able to comment on that
under sentence one sentence yeah that's
because no capitalist countries in the
world all right I know that that's their
perspective the other thing though is
there's a reality that if you had four
or five percent growth as we've seen 60
70 or 80 percent of that
growth Woodcote only to the very top and
it would do very little actually for the
people in the in the bottom 80 or 90
percent I mean I don't want to get Belga
down in the statistics but that is
unbelievably not true not true
it could be the Financial Times oh okay
Cappy Katie's book and you can read all
the other critiques of piketty's book I
mean what that man did with numbers you
know is fraudulent is basically but and
and the same is true of the latest
articles by his co-authors I can't
pronounce his name
si easy and and his is is co-author
anyway you know and you can't pronounce
size there's plenty of economic
literature which I read which is a vast
economic not philosophical not
ideological critique of those studies
and what what they do and the whole the
whole disengagement of productivity from
labor costs is such these are such wrong
ideas that again a repeated over and
over again and become like
institutionalized truths when in
economic literature they are all being
challenged on a daily basis not by
ideologues but by economists so I don't
think that's true but again you're
equivocating but through two things
you're equivocating between the world we
have today in capitalism we do not have
capitalism today there is no question
that today a disproportionate amount of
the wealth created goes to certain
people at the expense of other people a
big reason for that is the way offer to
Reserve functions that is like pumping
money into the financial system drives
up asset prices we boast about benefit
people already have assets and it
doesn't benefit people who don't yet
have assets so there's no question that
there is a distortion going on today but
that distortion is not driven by
capitalism it is driven by a very
statist I won't call it socialist but
status institution which is a Federal
Reserve I don't believe there should be
a Federal Reserve I believe in free
markets which means free markets and
money and free markets in banking and
and unregulated you know issuance of
currencies so you know to blame the
problems that exist today in the United
States on capitalism it is just it's
it's not what capitalism is and it just
it's just not true we'll listen you're
right that we we are
we of course don't have total
unregulated free-market capitalism there
are numerous markets where that's no of
course we don't have that but I think
what's deceptive or maybe distorted
distortive about what you're saying is
even if at the policy level you can say
the problem is the money that's pumped
into the economy by the Fed and there's
lots of people like you who want to get
rid of the Fed the problem with that is
the reason that we have those policies
is because of the disproportionate
influence over government of certain
industries that benefit from those
policies like banking and so on and so
forth so while you want it hold on hold
on so while you want to say the problem
is that the government apparatus exists
really the problem as I see it is that
the government apparatus has been
captured by certain industries including
the financial world and the financial
sector
so I'll partially agree with you okay
but your solution is the opposite of
what the solution should be well maybe
in the end the cause and effect is
opposite so I'll give you I'll give you
a quick example which you know when in
in 1995 let's say when Microsoft was the
largest corporation in the entire world
and massive how much money were they
spending on lobbying on trying to
capture politicians well zero no Lobby
nothing no lawyers nobody in Washington
DC not a single person no attempt to
capture anything and they were brought
in front of Congress and they were for
anybody like like Zuckerberg has been
recently you know in front of a panel
and on hatch a Republican senator from
Utah got up and started yelling at the
Microsoft executives you guys need to
start spending money here you guys need
a lobby you need to build a building you
need to get engaged and Microsoft walked
away from the meeting basically saying
you leave us alone we'll leave you alone
were not interested we don't want to
lobby we have nothing to gain from you
with her biggest company in the world
and we're doing a damn good job making
money and improving the lives of
billions of people around the planet six
months later knock on the door
we have in the government and we're here
to you know go accuse you of antitrust
violations what was the was the thing
that Microsoft god forbid had done to
screw our lives that it justified it
Justice Department investigation
they gave away a browser for free in
today with the idea was that they were
privileged being their browser over all
others and that it had you know a
destructive effect on competition
because of Netscape and whatever else
come on how many browsers you have today
all offered to you for free so the
argument was bogus still is bogus and
yet they for 15 for 20 years yeah they
have to deal with this ten years in
courts and ten years with a government
supervisor at Microsoft guess how much
money they spent on lobbying today I'm
sensing a lot a lot so the lesson
Microsoft learnt was government will not
leave you alone the only way to get rid
of lobbying the only way and the only
legitimate mall way to get rid of
lobbying is to get rid of government
power now you know you're on that
there's a completely different
interpretation of your Microsoft story
there's a different interpretation of
the Microsoft story which I'll present
and I don't know that it's the one I
would die on a hill defending but the
other interpretation of that would be
that Microsoft at that early stage where
they were making a ton of money and not
doing any lobbying the reason why they
were able to do that is as often is the
case government takes a while to figure
out how to regulate new technology and
new technology companies and I know
you're shaking your head but let me at
least get it out there because this is
an argument that is it's not a crazy
argument I mean we can discuss how valid
it is and so what really happened there
was once the government figured out hey
here's how the regulatory infrastructure
should be applied to this new industry
right Microsoft was no longer floating
under the radar and all of a sudden they
did what everybody else has to do that's
the other interpretation I'm sure but
either way at least the same conclusion
get gum and out of regulating business
get up coming out of the business of
business because they're not shouldn't
be in the business of coercing us or
what products to buy out how to buy them
and what what information we need and so
on then you don't have lobbying so take
take Google Google Alerts exactly
following your case it's all what
happened at Microsoft and said oh oh you
know government is regulating so from
day one literally you can go find this
when they want Google is be spreading
the money around Republicans Democrats
everybody gets right to eat and indeed
until recently nobody in the United
States has gone after Google they
Europeans have gone after Goku because
it didn't spread the money around there
into the same proportion they didn't
bribe themselves out of regulations to
the same proportion and now people are
starting to look at Google why because
the regulatory apparatus a good for both
the left and the right to go out to
Google for different reasons they both
want to go after them so you know yes
absolutely there is a the whole
mechanisms here but the only solution to
it is still right I want to make
politicians impotence when it comes to
economics and if that happens then
there's no incentive for me to lobby the
bigger the government becomes the more
powerful the government becomes the more
Tooting the government becomes the more
regulations you have the more lobbying
you allow there's a different
perspective as well which is if you
eliminate the money of lobbying and
donations from PACs and so on and so
forth and you set up some term limits
you would free our elected officials
because there's nothing on the other end
there's no consulting deal whatever to
just regulate the way that they believe
would be best and for many of them that
is regulate there is regulation that
many of them think would be best the
reason they're convinced out of it is
because they need to raise money for
that next reelection campaign but you
got you got a lot of problems they
because you think you think as most
status dude that you can come up with
just the right latest prentace well your
status I mean you believe in a big role
for the state I believe in a very
minimal role for the state I believe in
a slightly bigger role for the state
then then a centrist because I'm a
social democrat to me to me everybody in
the political the political spectrum
today is a statist okay all of them it
becomes an irrelevant term if everybody
falls under that category oh I mean you
know before there was freedom
everybody advocated for unfreedom it's
still advocate for freedom and try to
convince everybody to move to your
direction so the fact that nobody agrees
with me has no relevance to whether what
I say is true or not
okay I mean that's over if you if you if
you think about if you think about it
this way right why does and I don't want
to be just on Hillary think about I just
heard that because Hillary used to get
$250,000 for a speech at Goldman Sachs I
know what's her name Haley the former UN
Ambassador
Haylee nikki hailey is now getting six
figures for speeches now why do you
think they get six figures because I
know you don't get six figures and I
know I don't get six figures in eight
and I and I bet you both of us are both
more interesting speakers right can I
mean connections and the potential for
future engagements right I mean yeah you
know you're gonna outlaw that I mean at
what point do are you gonna say this
state is not gonna curse anymore I mean
I want to reduce cars you're not
increase I don't want more rules I don't
want to prevent people who are using
money to express themselves I believe
that is an expression of free speech if
I believe something is wrong I should be
able to shout it out from it I should be
able to by be able to buy billboards I
should be able to buy ads you know
that's a part of my speech but a company
giving a company giving nikki Haley
money because she might in the future be
involved in regulation that's not the
government coercing anybody those are
companies coercing nikki Haley to
eventually do what they want because
nikki Haley will have power over them
one day and they expect to get favors
backs right but if they can't give her
the money the starting point is ya know
if you want to prevent companies from
paying speaker fees for future
politicians because she's not running
for anything right now that's really
bitching wasn't running for anything
right you know when she got the 250,000
I you know so you're gonna have to have
a whole system of coercion where you're
telling people when they can't speak
when they can't speak who can pay who
cannot pay know that the easiest way to
get rid of cronyism and I'm a huge and
you know talk about corporate welfare
first thing I'll getting rid of if I
were you know God forbid president would
be everything to do with corporate
welfare zero subsidies zero deductions
from corporate taxes also local taxes to
zero but that's another issue zero and
then I would start lowering regulations
but the idea that that the government
should decide you know what they should
corporations whose their lot to pay and
not that allowed to pay what they can
lobby what they can't lobby I think I
think is unbelievably destructive and
only leads to worse outcomes yeah I'm
against getting so involved with
I'm against telling companies you can or
can't
than money in this way or that way I
mean unless they're committing crimes by
spending the money yeah okay but but I I
just I think that the framing of it
really comes down to you said you chose
a different starting point than I did so
depending on what we think is the
catalyst that starts the circle you end
up finding a different solution if you
believe the starting point of the
problem is the money versus the
government you're gonna end up with a
different prescription to some extent
that's true but but but really
fundamentally it's not the fundamental
here is it's the same with welfare the
fundamental here is coercion government
should not have the power over
corporations whether the corporation's
lobby or not government should not be in
a position to coerce corporations into
what they can and cannot do it shouldn't
cause individuals into what they can and
cannot do with their money it shouldn't
be taking from some to give to others
regulating some I just don't want people
to be dependent on I think it's immoral
for for an entity like government to be
dictating our lives to us and telling us
what we can and cannot do in every
single law
so I'm Rand used to criticize the right
and in those days the right I think was
marginally better than it was much
better than it is today but that's
because today it's so horrible it's not
because it was good then she used to say
the right kind of wants to leave you
free in the boardroom but wants to
regulate you in the bedroom and the left
wants to leave you kind of free in the
bedroom and to regulate you in the
boardroom I want to believe you free in
every aspect of your life yeah that's a
talking point that's common but it's
like North I think reasonable people
would agree that there it is not
equivalent to say that a government
telling you that two men can't get
married is the same thing as saying a
government shouldn't be able to say we
use taxation to fund schools like it
that they pretend that those are the
same thing and they're the same
relevance in society seems strange to me
well it seems to me that the issue of
education is much much worse than the
issue of gay marriage that is again I
don't think the government should be
involved in marriage I don't think the
government should be involved in
education okay any involvement in
education is a million times worse and
more disastrous in its consequences the
govern involved in marriage
I mean people could still live together
get stuff sex together you can still
cohabitate and so on but if you take a
poor kid and you inflict on in public
education and you do Tim what the public
schools do to kids I don't think they
can ever recover from that you know here
in Massachusetts here in Massachusetts
where schools are properly funded public
education is pretty good you know I went
to let me tell you so since we're
talking about childhood I went to school
in Massachusetts I went to two schools
in Massachusetts I went to Brookline
high school for one year great high
school and I went to a school before
Brookline high school which was
considered the top up to eighth grade
school in the country one of the top and
dukakis's kids went to the same school I
did this is in 75 and 76 74 to 76 and I
in two years in the Massachusetts public
educational system I fell basically two
years behind like hum in Israel no I'm
not kidding in science and math so not
two years I'm exaggerating for the
rhetoric rhetoric of flake you Mayhew
weeks behind B be honest you missed one
assignment a year and a half when I went
to Brooklyn high school I took eleventh
and twelfth grade math and science
courses in order to keep up with my
Israeli counterparts I'm not making this
up but no the educational system even in
the places where we think it's good yeah
is lousy
an educational system for poor kids by
the way Chicago spends a lot of money
and poor kids a lot of money and
educational outcomes are awful listen I
think that what you're describing what
you're describing about American kids
being behind I think it's true but I
don't think it's for the reasons you're
saying I think that in the United States
there is not currently a culture I mean
it the same thing happens in Argentina
where we are teaching critical thinking
from a young age we are teaching kids to
figure out why they believe what they
believe
I think it's leading to way more people
who are tricked into supporting Donald
Trump as a result I think it has
political repercussions but I think that
this is a real problem Donald Trump will
agree on but in a blaming educational
system for then I agree with you yeah
we're not teaching you eight things but
I think that's what happens when you
have a one-size-fit-all system that is
and and the more we centralize it the
worst it
instead of what I would like yes I would
like the next entrepreneur not to think
about how to create the next stupid app
for this neigh and Angry Birds that 76
right now a next entrepreneur to be
thinking about how to build a school
where they can educate where they can
teach where they can make it affordable
where they can appeal to a large public
I would like to see real competitive and
innovative markets where they matter and
I can't think of a realm more with
matters in education instead of having
that dictated by unions by school units
by teacher unions I want to see
competition I want to see innovation I
want to see entrepreneurship and I want
to see the same motivation it goes into
the next app going into the next great
educational product and you don't get
that as long as government not just
funds education but actually in a sense
controls the schools alright well we're
not going to resolve it but needless to
say my audience knows we are in
different positions on this all right
this is a good point to pause our
conversation we've been speaking with
Euron Brook chairman of the ein Rand
Institute and host of the Euron Brook
show this has been episode three of our
discussions and there will be a fourth
episode upcoming